philadelphia is a strange city that's a
strange city ah
they're um they're like famous
snack or meal right it's a philly cheese
steak
right that's not cheese no that's liquid
powdered sugar
yeah with yellow food coloring yeah
that's not stick
no that is i don't know what that is
those are steaks yeah those are for me
and ched
[Music]
yeah it's basically fake steak and fake
cheese
on a hero bread yeah okay and then as
their statue
they have [ __ ] rocky that's a fake
boxer yeah
and then they got a mayor that says the
word negro
this way cue it up mike marsh you know i
found out as the police chief that the
black in any area and particularly in
philadelphia he wants to know more than
i want
he wants to be secure in his home he
wants to be able to walk the street
in safety he wants to be able to have
his children educated without them being
shot or stabbed in school
every black is with you and if i thought
that the black community was against me
i would have not
run for mayor because uh
uh about six hundred thousand negroes
living okay
holy [ __ ] that's where you lost the
black vote right there
did you just he need negroes i've never
heard negro pronounced that way
i've never heard negro with an ni
because that was the mayor of
philadelphia he pronounced it negros
he was literally he stopped himself
midward
because he was a millisecond away from
letting one fly
yeah cause i mean philadelphia is a wild
town
i mean because he's being interviewed
on public television he almost said the
n-word yeah i mean
he kind of it was a you know that you
know that meme where that baby runs into
the room and then goes
and runs back yeah he kind of started
the word and went oh
get it that way holy [ __ ] isis have you
ever heard it pronounced
nigg rose now i have yeah can we play it
one more time let's just hear it one
more time
no camera tricks that that was him that
was about six hundred thousand negroes
live in philadelphia
i mean frankie
[Music]
yeah what do you think his pr team did
when they he said you think one of them
passed out
he obviously uh did not have a pr team
he didn't care
or his pr rep you know who his pr rep
was oh
his pr rep was a guy named vinnie from
the neighborhood yeah
everybody said listen when you make when
you talk about the blacks make sure
yeah make sure you you say the word and
you say it this way yeah his his pr guy
was a guy named paulie publicity
paulie from visiting from south philly
paulie publicity here from south philly
and uh yeah you just go up there and you
know just don't say the n-word but you
could come close yeah i gotta listen uh
yeah at least yeah he goes yeah just
don't say it full but you know
[ __ ] let the people know who you are
where you from
his wife is going frankie don't you have
to do an interview today
because i'm going to make you a couple
stakeholders when you came here
you came here make sure you call poorly
publicity so he can tell you because
how to say anything let's be crystal
clear about something yeah
they're 30-year me mrs rizzo yeah
unfortunately got disciplined a few
times she had a few black eyes for the
pictures
there was just a time or two wrong way
there was just a time or two where mr
and mrs rizzo showed up to an event
and unfortunately mrs rizzo had to bring
her friend lucille to do her makeup
it's just she had a black eye or two
because she was disciplined it's just
what it is that's what happens if you
put a little too much garlic in the
sauce
for frank rizzo